a recipe for oatmeal cookies calls for
two cups of flour for every three cups
of oatmeal how much flour is needed for
a big batch of cookies that uses 9 cups
of oatmeal so they tell us they tell us
that we have two cups of flours let me
write that down two cups of flour two
cups of flour we need two cups of flour
for every three cups of oatmeal for
every three cups of oatmeal three cups
of oatmeal oatmeal now we need to figure
out is how much flour is needed for a
big batch that uses 9 cups of oatmeal so
this is the same thing as and this is
what we need to figure out we need to
figure out how much so let's just call
that the amount of flour we need for
this larger batch let's call it X that's
equal to X cups of flour X cups of flour
X cups of flour 4 9 cups of oatmeal for
every 9 cups of oatmeal 9 cups of
oatmeal oatmeal so all we're saying look
we need 2 cups of flour for every 3 cups
of oatmeal that has to be the same as X
for every 9 cups the proportion has to
hold these ratios have to simplify to
the same fraction now the easiest way to
do this we can just get rid of the cups
of flour and the cups of oatmeal for now
and we can just view this as a simple
proportion problem where it's 2 over 3
is equal to x over 9 and the simplest
way to solve this is to multiply both
sides of this equation by 9 and the
reason why we're multiplying by 9 is so
it cancels out with this 9 in the
denominator you can view it as
multiplying both sides of the equation
by 9 over 1 so if you multiply both
sides by 9 over 1 the left-hand side
you'll have a 9 in the numerator 3 in
denominator you can divide them both by
3 so 9 divided by 3 is 3 3 divided by 3
is
so your left side of the equation is
three times two over one so it's six
over one and that's going to be equal to
well this sign in the numerator and this
9 in the denominator they cancel out
they can both be divided by nine so they
cancel out so that is equal to x over
one or you can just view both both of
the six over one is the same thing as 6x
over one it's the same thing as X so we
get X X is equal to six so we've just
figured out if the recipe calls for two
cups of flour for every three cups of
oatmeal that means that we need six cups
of flour for every nine cups of oatmeal
so we figured out that X is equal to six